I have a bunch of questions let's try to
get through these as we can
well see before we get started I just
have to address the rain that's the
thing now here in Hawaii just so you
know everybody hear it when it rains
it's considered a blessing so that means
this interview is gonna go completely
off the tracks but it's ok the most
takes hobs are sha sha did but by way of
hops because I'm like a shark we're
smell blood in the water I know that I
could get him laughing because as you
know you've known Jason for a very long
time he doesn't he's not a big laugher
and he's not a big smile on said he's
quite serious so the moment I could
sniff he's almost ready to go I'm
jumping on it I'm making him laugh who
was most likely to get it on the first
take Hobbs or show me for a hundred
percent Hobbs the fastest at getting out
of their trailer
Hobbs or sha neither one of us that
would be JA probably um who has more
hair Hobbs our show on which part of the
body I was not expecting that answer it
would be him uh got it uh who is faster
at learning their lines
Hobbs our Shah Hobbs is that from like
the wrestling history could you can just
like a look at it you know what that's a
good question so yeah so for wrestling I
would have to go out and just memorize
these long monologues that would be
sometimes twenty minutes straight but
then also I would just listen to the
crowd and see where they wanted to go
and I would just go that way so it's a
lot of bad living I'm just smarter I'm
switching into a new thing which is I
want to compare you guys against other
action stars so who wins in a fight
Hobbs in Shaw or Jason Bourne is it a
triple threat so it's you two versus
Jason I guess Oh we'll take them down
okay
Hobbs in Shaw or Deadpool
well Deadpool would kill Shaw just like
that then it would come down to Hobbes
and Deadpool and then well that could go
either way
Hobbes and Shaw or John wick Oh again
John wick would put a bullet right
through Shaw's head and then he'd
probably pull one through Hobbes head to
Hobson shot where John MacLean John
McClane would kick both of our asses
public Shaw or rocky with the rocky
theme music in the scene okay what rocky
from which movies oh that's a very good
question let's go rocky for rocky for
got it off of the drug Ivan Drago win
rocky for Hobson's Shaw or Chev Chelios
from crank that would go under the
category of who gives a [ __ ] up shot or
Bruce Lee Oh hands down Bruce Lee got it
and my last one
Hobson Shaw or Ripley in aliens Ripley
from aliens for sure would kill Shaw
then she would have to go after Hobbes
and Hobbes will break out the tequila
see let's have a drink let's not fight
got it then Ripley would rip off Hobson